we have an amazing show tonight just
fantastic what was that noise
oh I'm sorry Conan it's my new violin I
was at Ellen and she gave everyone in
the audience a genuine Stradivarius okay
that's that's that's right Ellen gives
her audience great gifts yeah yeah Ellen
also gave everyone an authentic gold
medal from the 32 Olympics it's great
that's yeah sounds impossible but anyway
I should explain that woman was in our
audience last night she showed us all
the gifts she got yesterday at The Ellen
Show
take a look why do you have a cappuccino
machine I came here straight from Ellen
she's going for 12 Days of Giveaways
Ellen also got me an iPhone 9 Ellen gave
me a pair of jon Hamm's used basketballs
also got each of us this amazing
terracotta statue of a warrior by
Brandon MRI machine
Allen gave each of us our own person
personal Fabio - operated
[Music]
yeah look those gifts are wonderful
Ellen's terrific I just can't do that
it's a lot of work oh come on if Ellen
can give away a silver toilet filled
with ancient Persian rubies work at you
that's nice but I happen to believe the
greatest gift I can give my audience is
the gift of laughter I've been here two
nights in a row and I haven't laughed
once look ma'am I'm really sorry I'm not
handing out gifts it's not gonna happen
what kind of monster are you hello can
you believe this creep no dips I don't
know what to say about that
[Applause]
[Applause]
what's up Conan okay well nice to see
you Ellen oh it's just I I'm this woman
keeps talking about all the gifts you're
giving out on the show and it's costing
me a bit of a problem yeah I'm surprised
she makes it over here so quickly right
after the show so you never give I mean
look I agree gift of laughter is the
most important gift with people like
free stuff also you never give them
anything
I have yeah half a sleeve of gluten-free
Fig Newtons in my car I could handle
yeah yeah well I set the bar pretty low
I actually would you rather have the the
gluten-free Fig Newtons which is hard to
say or would you rather have something
that I brought maybe
[Applause]
[Applause]
all right so who here loves music
[Applause]
who here has a head
all right dr. Dre made the greatest
headphones you're all going to go home
with beats solo2 headphones by doctors
[Applause]
you